What do you mean when you're the only one left? Do you want to become a
bait? We, the
Garo tribe, let our prey escape.
[Music] You
look like you've just released a gunfire.
[Music]
But I'm going to become your wife, a
strong one.  It's a woman of my tribe's honor to wait so long.
I can become the wife of a strong man like Aji-dono. I
don't like fighting to begin with. I was
summoned as a candidate for a hero, so what's the point?
Even if I don't have any skills, if I win, I will be able to prove the strength of my husband who beat me.No, I don't care if we
just pretend to be a couple.I feel like if I'm with my
husband, I can
even defeat the Demon King.
We only need to sleep in one bed, so it
's only natural since we're husband and wife. Husband:
[Music]
Eh
OG